COMMUNICATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYERS WE
MUST IMPLEMENT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING AND THEN HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
AND IT HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WE'LL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WE WILL NOW BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN EIGHT TWO. ZERO
ZERO EIGHT FOUR. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE AND OR
SENATE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATE
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. PRESS
ONE ONE TIME AND THEN PATIENTLY
WAIT WE WERE SIGNED TO A QUEUE
MUCH RECEIVE YOUR LIGHT NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN A QUEUE TO THE
MODERATOR CULTURE LINE NUMBER.
AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ADMITTED. READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. WE ASK THAT YOU MUTE
WHATEVER DEVICE YOU WERE
LISTENING ON. THAT BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING TO AVOID ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK OUR MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
ROOM. OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
NEEDED. EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MAINTAINED TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS AND THAT'S CLOSE. TO
THE MATTER AS CUSTOMARY MAYBE
SOME LIKE TIMES AND. WE ASK FOR
YOUR PATIENCE- TODAY WE HAVE
FOUR BILLS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
AGENDA HOWEVER ONE HAS BEEN
PULLED AT AB TWO FORTY TWO
FROM. SWIMMING BEHOLDEN HAS
BEEN PULLED AND THAT WILL BE
HEARD ON AT A FUTURE MEETING.
THAT BEFORE WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATION THE BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM IF THE
CONSULTANT CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SHARE A COMMON. HERE'S
SURE A MAN HERE. VICE CHAIR
DOLLY. YEAH VICE CHAIR DOLLY
HERE. BECKER YEAH BETTER
HEARING. GORGEOUS PRESIDENT
PORGES PRESENT. BRADFORD.
DONALD. INTOLERANCE HERE CONSOL
IS HERE. GROSS HERE. GROWTH
HERE. HERTZBERG WESSEL. MCGUIRE.
MAN YOUR MAN HERE. RUBIO
PRESIDENT RUBIO PRESENTS. STERN.
CHAIR THERE'S YOU HAVE CORN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED AT THIS
POINT WE'LL HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR WHO IS HERE AND THAT IS-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
PRESENTING AB TEN FIFTY EIGHT
SO MY RIVER FLOORS YOURS THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AS IT IN
THE STILL EXTENDS AN EXISTING
PILOT PROGRAM OVERSEEN BY THE
CPC TO ASSESS WATER CUSTOMERS
INTEREST AND USE THE BILL
PAYMENT OPTIONS INCLUDING
CREDIT CARD DEBIT CARD AND
PREPAID CARDS. HOWEVER THROUGH
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE WE
HAVE AGREED TO TAKE A MOMENT
THAT WE TRANSACTION FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH ELECTRONIC
PAYMENTS THAT WILL PROTECT LOW
INCOME. CUSTOMERS FROM ANY
SOCIALIST COST RECOVERY BY
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY- WITH
THE CLASS AND I WILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FIRST WE'LL HEAR
FROM ANY MEMBERS IN SUPPORT-
ANY ACTIVE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF
THIS YEAR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ASSEMBLYMEMBER. OKAY
SO WE WOULD THEN ASK FOR
ANYBODY SPEAKING IN THE ROOM.
ONE TWELVE I SEE NO ONE- IF WE
COULD GO TO THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR. ANY PEOPLE WHICH I'M
SURE YOU DO ACTUALLY HAVE EVAN
JACOBS ON THE LINE AND SUPPORT
OKAY CAN WE PLEASE HEAR FROM MR
JACOBSON. MR TAKEN FIVE
HUNDRED. HELLO EVAN JACOBS- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS SPONSORING
THE LEGISLATION WE REPRESENT
NINETY FOUR PC REGULATED WATER
UTILITIES AROUND THE STATE WE
PROVIDE WATER SERVICE ABOUT 16%
OF RESIDENTS WHO SAY THE
CALIFORNIA AND HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF MAYBE TEN
FIFTY EIGHT. THAT REALLY CROSS
ABOUT USING TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE
BILL PAYMENTS EASIER SAFER AND
MORE CONVENIENT HI- WE STARTED
TALKING ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION
SIMILAR LEGISLATION ABOUT SIX
YEARS AGO BUT OBVIOUSLY IN THE
LAST SIXTEEN MONTHS
CONVERSATION UPON FROM TALKING
UP MAKING BILL PAYMENTS EASIER
TO MAKING THEM SAFER- IN THIS
YEAR OF COKE THAT GETS REALLY
PART OF IT NOW PRESS LOG PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN AS WELL AS IN
THE ISUE CUSTOMER COMPLAINT.
CONVENIENCE- LIKE CAME IN TO
REACH PART OF OUR BUSINESS WE
ALL THE SMALL FORMS OF PAYMENT
TO CRASH TO BANK ACCOUNT
WITHDRAWAL. THE ONLY FOR
PAYMENT HAVE A DISH COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM BORN-
USING THE OF COURSE. BLACK
CHRONIC PAIN CREDIT DEBT CARD
SO WE NEED TO THE TREE OTHER
FORMS OF PAYMENT SIMILAR. AND
I'M PLEASED WITH THE AMENDMENTS
WILL TAKE AND THAT PROVIDES A
GREATER LEVEL OF PROTECTION FOR
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS. WE'RE
TOLD MY REPAIR SYSTEMS PROGRAMS
SO- I. THANK ASSEMBLYWOMAN
GARCIA FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE OVER THE LAST SIX
YEARS AND- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I UNDERSTAND WE
ALSO HAVE MR PERATIS. ON THE
PHONE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. THE
GOOD UP. MY NAME IS JOHN GRANDE
AND I AM EMPLOYED BY GOLDEN
STATE WATER COMPANY A KEY PC
REGULATED WATER UTILITY. AND
THE MANAGER OF REGULATORY
AFFAIRS- I'M PROVIDING
TESTIMONY THIS AFTERNOON IN
SUPPORT OF BABY TEN FIFTY EIGHT
WE CAN MAKE PERMANENT A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WOULD ALLOW. WATER
UTILITIES TO WAIVE THE
TRANSACTION FEE FOR CUSTOMERS
PAYING BY CREDIT CARD DEBIT
CARD AND PREPAID CARD. AND
ALLOW WATER UTILITIES TO
RECOVER THE COST OF OPERATING
THIS PROGRAM FROM ALL OF THE
CUSTOMERS EXCLUDING LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS. GOING TO A WATER
COMPANY SUPPORTS THIS BILL
BECAUSE ACCEPTING CREDIT OR
DEBIT CARD TO THE FORM OF
PAYMENT. IS A BASIC AND
FUNDAMENTAL FUNCTION OF ANY
MAJOR BUSINESS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IT IS UNDERSTANDABLE WHY A
CUSTOMER WOULD WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE CONVENIENCE
AND SECURITY. A CREDIT OR DEBIT
CARD PROVIDED. GOLDEN STATE
BEGAN A PILOT PROGRAM TO FUND
THE COST OF CUSTOMER CREDIT
CARD PAYMENTS BEGINNING IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. GENERATING
POSITIVE FEEDBACK FROM OUR
CUSTOMERS. GIVEN THE IMPACT OF
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
TWENTY TWENTY IN THE SHORT
DURATION OF THE TIME THE PILOT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN IN PLACE.
GOLDEN STATE HAS NOT HAD A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF TIME TO
QUANTIFY THE MANY CUSTOMER
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PILOT PROGRAM. HOWEVER FROM
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN THE TOTAL PAYMENT MADE
BY COHEN A CUSTOMER USING
CREDIT CARD DEBIT CARD OR
ELECTRONIC CHECK SERVICES.
INCREASED AT AN ANNUAL AVERAGE
OF APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN
PERCENT. OUR EXPECTATION IS
THAT THE CONTINUED WAIVER OF
TRANSACTION FEES WILL GENERATE
MORE DESIRE ON GOLDEN STATE
CUSTOMERS CARD. HE USED THE
PAYMENT OPTION DESCRIBED IN
MAYBE TEN FIFTY EIGHT. IN
CLOSING I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
A BABY TEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATE OR ANYBODY. ELSE IN
THE QUEUE WISHING TO GIVE THEIR
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. TEN FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. TEN FIFTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYBODY
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SAYING NOBODY- MODERATOR
AND ASK YOU IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE. WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO AB. TEN
FIFTY EIGHT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN FIFTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THE B. TEN
FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ENTER. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WOULD. TURN IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS TO SEE IF ANYBODY HAS
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ON THIS
BILL SENATOR GROVE YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I AM THROUGH THE CHAIR-
THIS PILOT PROGRAM STARTED WHEN
DO YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION
MA'AM. SIX YEARS AGO AND I
CARRIED THAT US WELL OKAY AND
WITHIN THAT SIX YEARS DO YOU
HAVE AN ESTIMATED DOLLAR AMOUNT
OF WHAT THE FEES WERE. NOT THE
ACTUAL BILL ITSELF- BUT THE
FEES ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILLS.
I DO NOT. THE BILL IS PASSED IT
WAS IMPLEMENTED A YEAR LATER
AND THEN BECAUSE OF CODE WITH
SOME OF THE DATA COLLECTION WAS
ALSO AFFECTED. NINE OKAY SO
JUST JUST TO BE REALLY CLEAR I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO RIGHT I REALLY DO- AND I
THINK EVERYBODY'S MIND IS ALL
ONLINE SOME OF ITGOES TO A
CREDIT CARD ACTUALLY A LOT OF
IT DOES BECAUSE WE GET CABALLOS
POINTS AND- MY HUSBAND'S
FAVORITE PLACE TO SHOP. AND BUT
I DO HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
FEES I'M JUST UNSURE WHO'S
GOING TO PAY THE CREDIT CARD
FEES THAT'S MY ONLY CONCERN.
THERE'S ALSO LIFE AMONG ALL
CUSTOMERS THAT CALLED LIKE ANY
OTHER FEES THAT MIGHT OF
NORMALLY HAVE HAPPENED FOR. ANY
OTHER BILL PAYMENTS EXCEPT FOR
THE CARE CUSTOMERS TO REALIGN
COME. YOU WOULD BE EXCLUDED
FROM ANY OF THESE COSTS. IT
WOULD JUST BE A LIKE A- SPREAD
OVER ALL CUSTOMERS PLEASE AND
THAT PAY BILLS REGARDLESS IF
THEY USE THAT. CREDIT CARD
PAYMENT OR NOT CORRECT THAT'S
THE WAY WE DO IF YOU MAIL IN A
CHECK THAT'S IF YOU DO A PHONE.
PAYMENT AT LEAST AT THOSE THOSE
PAYMENTS OUT ACROSS EVERYBODY
CURRENTLY AS WELL. AND YOU
DON'T KNOW APPROXIMATELY HOW
MUCH THOSE FEES ARE THOUGH I
MEAN ARE WE TALKING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS DO YOU THINK THREE
TOPPING. MILLION YOU KNOW LIKE
HOW MUCH IS GOING TO HELP MY
CONCERN IS I GUESS IS THE RATE
INCREASES. FOR THESE- THESE
TRANSACTION FEES. CAN I AN
INSIGHT ON HOW THE DATA BUT I
WILL SAY THIS- MORE AND MORE OF
OUR CONSUMERS ARE EXPECTING TO
DO THIS ONLINE AND IT'S
ACTUALLY CHEAPER FOR. ONLINE
THAN TO. WALK INTO A FACILITY
OR TO WRITE A CHECK AND HAVE
THAT PROCESS. SO AS WE ARE
MOVING FROM ONE TO THE OTHER I
WOULD I. SYSTEM THAT WE MIGHT
EVEN HAVE SOME SAVINGS HERE. I
WOULD AND I WOULD ALSO ASK I
KNOW YOU HAVE A WITNESS IS ON
IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER
AND I THINK THE STUDY YOU'RE
REFERRING TO IS THAT CPUC STUDY
THAT. AGAIN IT WAS HARD TO LOOK
AT THE DATA BECAUSE- OF CODE
AND EVERYTHING- BUT I THINK
WOULD BE ASSUMING THEY WERE
SAYING TO SOCIALIZE ACROSS
EVERYBODY AND THE REPORT I SAW
I THOUGHT MAYBE EVERYBODY'S
WOULD GO UP ABOUT FIFTY CENTS-
BUT THEY- THEY WEREN'T QUITE
SURE AND AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE
DATE IS NOT QUITE RIGHT. I
WOULD I WOULD KNOW WHAT THIS
BILL IS GOING TO ANOTHER-COMMITTEE. I BELIEVE AND SO
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO HEAR IT
THERE AS WELL- AND- I BELIEVE
THAT WE DONE SOME REMEMBER- I'M
SORRY TO DO. HE WAS A WITNESS
IS GOING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT-
IN. IN RESPONSE TO SENATOR THE
CENTER FROM BAKERSFIELD
QUESTION ABOUT HOW MUCH WILL
EVERYBODY'S BILL BE RAISED. AND
HOW MUCH ARE THE FINES
CURRENTLY THAT PEOPLE ARE
PAYING WHEN THEY USE- AT THIS
MOMENT. TRANSACTION. TO TAKE
OUT A READER HAS. DIFFERENT
DREAMS MIGHT MIGHT. HELLO RIGHT
NOW. SEVEN JACOBS ARE DRAWN FOR
IT YOU. EVAN JACOBS OKAY CAN
YOU ANSWER THAT QUESTION MISTER
JACOBS. I THANK THANK YOU FOR
ASKING THAT SOME TO. EVERY
EVERY COMPANY HAS CLEARLY
DIFFERENT JEEZ MY COMPANY
CHARGES A DOLLAR NINETY FIVE
GENERALLY PREACH CREDIT CARD
TRANSACTIONS ACTUALLY CHARGED
WITH THIRD PARTY PROCESSOR- BUT
CERTAINLY MEMBER GARCIA'S
CORRECT EVERY FORM OF PAYMENT
HAVE SOME COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. PERHAPS BY FAR AND AWAY
THE LARGEST PARKS ARE PEOPLE
WALKING IN WITH CASH BECAUSE
OF- THE DIFFICULTY IN THE
SECURITY. CHECKS YOU NEED ON
HANDLING CASH CASES ARE MOST
EXPENSIVE FORM OF PAYMENT SO WE
EXPECT SOME COST SHIFTING THAT
OCCURRED HERE AND WHAT YOU
KNOW. GENERATING COST SAVINGS
WE ALSO GOING TO BE SOME OTHER
BENEFITS TO IT I THINK THE PC
REPORT WAS VERY CONSERVATIVE
THAT UP TO FIFTY CENTS. PER
BILL PER CUSTOMERI MY HOPE IS
THAT WE WILL GENERATE MORE
SAVINGS- INVOLVED AFTER YOU
CLICK ON THE PAYMENTS AND HAVE
AN ACTUAL LOWER IMPACT ON OUR
CUSTOMERS- HOPEFULLY THAT
ANSWERS YOURQUESTION HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANYTHING ELSE. IT DOES I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO GO BECAUSE
YOU KNOW. LIKE I SAID ALMOST
EVERYTHING IS ONLINE AND IN YOU
PAY BY CREDIT CARD OR OR JUST
TO HAVE BEEN LOWER THINGS LIKE
THAT I JUST HAD A CONCERN YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIANS PAY THE
HIGHEST UTILITY AND ENERGY
RATES ALMOST IN THE NATION AND
I JUST HAD A CONCERN ABOUT AN-
EVEN ADDITIONAL FIFTY CENTS.
AND TO THOSE COST AND BUT I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE- WHERE THE
AUTHOR IS GOING WITH THIS BILL
SO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING. ME
TO ANSWER THAT- ASKED THAT
QUESTION. VERY MUCH I WE A
CENTER DOT WISHING TO BE BACK.
IN THEN AFTER THAT CENTERED.
YEAH I JUST ONE TO SPEAK THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT BUSINESS
DOES. HE IN ANY. OUT THERE IS.
PROCESSING CREDIT CARDS IN YOU
KNOW IT IS IT A BURDEN
SOMETIMES ON AN INDIVIDUAL
BASIS- TO BE CHARGING YOUR
PEOPLE BACK. YOUR DOOR DIRECTLY
AND SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME
UNFORTUNATELY IT DOES TAKE
STATE LEGISLATION TO GET THAT
DONE. EVEN ON THE COUNTY LEVEL
SOME MIGHT TRY TO GET DONE IN.
IN NAPA COUNTY- FOR MANY YEARS
AND HOPEFULLY THERE'S MORE OF
THIS WILL HELP BECAUSE IT JUST
MAKES IT EASIER. FOR CONSUMERS
TO PAY IT'S MORE CONVENIENT FOR
THE CONSUMER MORE CONVENIENT
FOR THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
THIS SIDE- I THINK IT'S A GOOD
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT
CENTRE DELHI. I JUST LIKE TO
ADD ON TO IT I THINK I RECALL
IN THE SILLY WOMAN BROUGHT HER
BILL BEFORE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
BE A SAVINGS IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE
TO WRITE THE CHECK BUY A STAMP.
THEN SOMEBODY PROCESS ON THE
OTHER END THE RETAILERS
ACTUALLY SAVINGS EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S A COST SHIFT TO IT
OBVIOUSLY THERE WOULD BE A
SAVINGS AND SO WILL I HI I
BELIEVE I SUPPORTED THE STUDY
BILL AND I KNOW WE DID GET THE
INFORMATION BUT- THOSE OF US IN
BUSINESS NO IT TAKES MORE TIME
TO PROCESS AND HOURS AND IN
THE- PERSONNEL. THAT IT DOES IT
JUST TRANSFER THE MONEY
STRAIGHT TO THE CHECKING
ACCOUNT SO FOR THOSE REASONS-
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. THIRTY DOES A MOTION
CENTER. WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE I KNOW. A
SPOKESWOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES I WANT TO CLARIFY
FOR THE RECORD THE M. AND THEN
I SPOKE ABOUT WAS TAKEN IN THE
PREVIOUS COMMITTEE NO I'M I'M
IN TEARS TODAY. AT MYSTIC CLASS
WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB TEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA. MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. A
BY. AIKMAN HI DOLLY. DOLLY NINE
VICTOR HI BECKER I FORGES.
BRADFORD ON BRADFORD HI DOT.
DOT NINE GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I
GROSS. GROSS HI HERTZBERG.
WESSEL REQUIRE. MAN HI MAN I
RUBIO HI RUBIO I. STERN. SURE
THERE ARE NINE EIGHTIES OKAY
THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT BUT WE WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHAS HERE NEXT UP WE HAVE A
B. THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICE
FUND BROADBAND ADOPTION ACCOUNT.
AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT THERE
IS- NO THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION OR LEAD SUPPORT IS
THAT CORRECT SORRY MEMBER. IN
THAT IS CORRECT MA'AM SURE
RIGHT THIS SHOULD BE A VERY
EFFICIENT. THANK YOU SHARES
SENATORS BABY THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE WOULD ALLOW. RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS THE ABILITY FOR
THE BROADBAND ADOPTION ACCOUNT
ACCESS. CURRENTLY THEY ARE
EXCLUDED FROM. BEING ELIGIBLE
FOR THESE FUNDS. WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE IS IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. AND EVEN IN SOME OF
OUR URBAN AREAS THERE ARE
PLACES WHERE THE CHURCH AXES
THE COMMUNITY CENTER THAT
HAPPENS TO BE THE ONLY PLACE
FOR KIDS OFTEN TO GO TO AFTER
SCHOOL. IN WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS MAKE SURE AND WE DID A
LOT OF WORK IN ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY ENSURING THAT LARGER
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS ARE ABLE
TO TAP INTO THIS. VERY SIMPLY
THIS IS WHERE KIDS GO AFTER
SCHOOL. WHEN THEY'RE GONE AND
AWAY FROM THEIR PARENTS AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO INTERNET JUST
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE. JUST
BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN POOR
DISADVANTAGED AREAS WHETHER BE
URBAN OR RURAL THEY DESERVE
ACCESS TO. CENTERS ASK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANYBODY
AND YOU SAID YOU SAID THERE'S
NOBODY LEAD SUPPORT TECH
CORRECT THERE'S NO LEE
WITNESSES OKAY. ANYBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WISH TO MAKE ANY
COMMENT SEEING NONE. MODERATOR
I WOULD ASK YOU TO OPEN THE
PHONE LINE TO SEE IF ANYBODY'S
THERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE GREAT.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WE'LL COME BACK TO THE BODY
MANY MEMBERS IN THE CENTERS
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
US SENATOR BECKER FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR DODD FULLVISION RUBIO.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER FOR THIS.
WHICH IS A QUESTION WHICH WHICH
KINDS OF. ORGANIZATION JUST SO
I CAN UNDERSTAND ARE YOU TRYING
TO GET THIS BILL WHO WHO ARE
NOT. NOT CURRENTLY QUALIFY
UNDER THE- EXISTING PROVISIONS
FOR NON PROFITS WERE FOR
NONPROFITS REVEALS TRANSACTION
ABSOLUTELY CENTER CURRENTLY-
BUT YOU'LL FIND IF YOU DIVE
DEEP INTO THE- WORDING IN THE
NEXUS OF NON PROFITS IS THAT A
RELIGIOUS NONPROFIT
INSTITUTION. CAN ACTUALLY TAP
INTO THESE FUNDS BUT IF IT'S A
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTION STATE
CHURCH OR SYNAGOGUE OR A MOSQUE.
OR C. TEMPLE OR OR ANYTHING OF
THAT NATURE THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO GO. IN WITH THE STILL DOES
IS JUST OPEN THIS UP FOR THEM.
BOY IT'S WRITTEN SO THIS ISN'T
FOR THE BIG RICH ONES THIS IS
FOR THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
ANYWHERE ELSE- SO THAT'S THE
ATTEMPT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO- IF THERE'S ANYTHING IN IT.
THE YOU SEE THE NEED TO WORK
I'M ALWAYS OPEN- AS A LOT OF.
YOUR COLLEAGUES KNOW- ALWAYS
HAPPY TO LOOK AT WAYS TO AMEND
IT MAKE IT BETTER- BUT THE GOAL
HERE IS TO MAKE SURE. THAT YOU
KNOW WHEN. THESE COMMUNITIES
NEED HELP. ESPECIALLY WE SAW
THOSE WITH KOBE- ESPECIALLY IN
THE RURAL AREAS. IF THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE ACCESS THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS AND THESE KIDS ARE
ARE LEFT IN THE DUST. WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN. OKAY THANK YOU. AND I
WILL SAY I WAS REMISS IN NOT
ASKING FOR OPPOSITION SO I WILL
AT THIS TIME- DID WE KNOW
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
BITTER ANY OPPOSITION EITHER IN
ONE TWELVE SEEING NONE ARE ON
THE PHONE LINES. MODERATOR
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH O SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF A. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN. ZERO WE HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK
WE'LL GO TO ASPEN- DIED BY
SENATOR RUBIO FALL BY CENTER
CONSOLES. I MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD I KNOW
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. NOT ONLY
FOR THE RURAL COMMUNITIES AS HE
STATED BUT I ALSO KNOW THE
TEACHER THAT A LOT OF OUR INNER
CITY COMMUNITY. EVEN IN THE
HEART OF ART YOU KNOW OVER
POPULATED CITIES RELY ON THESE
INSTITUTIONS FOR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS TUTORING AND THE LIKES
I KNOW THAT THERE IS QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE DEFINITION I BELIEVE
BUT- I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL COME TO A
RESOLUTION IF THEY HAVEN'T
ALREADY AND WHAT THE DEFINITION
OF RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS MEAN
AND WITH THAT I ALSO. WANT TO
ADD MY NAME TO IT AND SUPPORT
HIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR AND I
WANNA I ALSO THINK THAT THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- I DO TO HAVE A
QUESTION ON THE DEFINITION THAT
I KNOW YOU WILL CONTINUE
WORKING ON AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SITTING DOWN WITH YOU AND
TALKING ABOUT THAT IS IT I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE PARALLEL-
POLICIES WITH- THE CAST OF
FUNDS. MOVING AHEAD ALONG WITH
THE MAY REVISE PROPOSAL WE
JUST- SAID YES TO BUDGET TODAY
AND I HOPE THAT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS COMING
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT WILL FOCUS ON THESE
EFFORTS ESPECIALLY WITH OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- BUT AS
WE KNOW THE CAST OF THIS
ALREADY OVER SUBSCRIBED SO WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN. WHEN WE'RE ADDING NEW
FOLKS INTO THE SYSTEM TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT- THAT THAT YOU
KNOW THEY ARE THAT THEY ARE-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WARRANT
LISTS- YOU KNOW VERY LIMITED
FUNDING BUT THAT WE'RE DOING SO
IN A WAY THAT'S EFFICIENT AND
SO I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND-
SUPPORT THE BILL TOO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CENTER
DELHI. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
AM CONFUSED- WHO'S SEMIS WORK
IN THIS AREA A LOT OF WHAT IF
YOUR NONPROFIT YOUR NONPROFIT I
DON'T THINK THERE'S- SO I'VE
HEARD KIND OF A THEME HERE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT LIKE WHAT'S
THE DEFINITION OR WHAT SO I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
BILL ACTUALLY DOES. I'M I'M
SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN VERY
FRUSTRATED WITH. THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE NO ABILITY TO AUDIT THE
NON PRODUCTS AND- NONPROFITS
AND REALLY FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE'RE GETTING FOR THE MOUNT OF
MONEY THAT'S GOING TO THERE
THAT'S FINE DISCUSSION I LOVED
OUT. OF ACTUALLY ALONG WITH THE
SENATOR FROM GARDENIA. SEND A
LETTER TO THE J. LACK-
COMMITTEE TO ACTUALLY AUTOS AND
FIND OUT WHAT WHAT WE'RE DOING
THERE BUT I WOULD. I'M CONFUSED
THAT IF YOUR NONPROFIT YOUR NON
PROFIT DOESN'T MATTER IF
YOU'RE- A RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATION OR YOUR- I GUESS
LITTLE LEAGUE OR OR SOME OTHER.
BECAUSE OF MAYBE THE MORE
DEFINITION FOR ME I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THIS BILL
REALLY. ALERTS HEADED AND WHAT
IT WHAT IS WHERE THE- I GUESS
WHO EXCLUDING. OKAY THANK YOU
ARE YOU WILLING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO
IN YOUR CLOTHES AND IT AND I
THINK I WILL JUST SAY TO THAT
POINT CENTER DOWN THE SERVICE
HAD THAT THAT THAT THAT
CONCERN. IN THIS BILL I THINK
WE'RE ALL WE'RE ALL GOOD ON THE
COMMUNICATIONS UTILITY PART BUT
I THINK SOME OF THE IT IS GOING
TO JUDICIARY NEXT WORDS SOME OF
THOSE MORE LEGAL QUESTIONS WILL
BE ANSWERED BUT THAT THE SUMMER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADDRESSES IN
OUR IN YOUR CLOTHES I'M FINE
WITH THE DRESSING ON THE
CLOTHES OKAY. ANY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. OKAY AND WE DO KNOW
THAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO DO
DISH NEXT IF IT SHOULD PASS
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
DODD. ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
SENATOR IN IN IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- CENTER DOLLY- WE WHEN
WE DRIVE IN THE NONPROFIT WORLD
AROUND A LOT OF US IN IN MYSELF
INCLUDED- WHEN I WAS FIRST
LOOKING AT THIS AND REALLY
THINKING DEEP INTO IT. WAS THE
NON PROFITS AND ON PROFIT
YOU'RE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
JUDICIAL SIDE THE LEGALITY SIDE
IT'S NOT. I MYSELF ON ONCE UPON
A TIME WAS A NATIONAL VICE
PRESIDENT FOR A NONPROFIT THE
NATIONAL VETERANS FRATERNITY.
HE WAS A NON PROFIT FIVE
NINETEEN. BECAUSE BEING A
VETERANS IT'S A DIFFERENT COAT.
WE KNOW THIS WITH. OUR
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEES. R.
FIVE WILL FORCE VERSUS FIVE OH
THREES VERSUS DIFFERENT
CATEGORICAL NUMBERS. IN SO WHEN
YOU DIVE INTO THE NONPROFIT
CODES THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT MEETINGS THAT COME
INTO PLAY- AS WE MOV INTO
JUDICIARY I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO LOOK INTO FINITE IN MORE
DETAIL THIS. THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL. IT IS VERY EXTREMELY
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO HELP
THOSE WHO ARE IN DISADVANTAGED
AREAS. WHETHER IT BE THE RURAL
AREAS. WHO SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
IT IN THE COMMUNITY CENTERS IN
THOSE AREAS SO HAPPEN TO BE
RELIGIOUS CENTERS. AND S. WAS
MENTIONED ALREADY BY SENATOR
RUBIO. SOME OF OUR INNER CITY
AREAS. HAVE THESE VERY SMALL
RELIGIOUS CENTERS. IN THIS IS
THE ONLY PLACE FOR KIDS DO
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND GET
HELP WITH THEIR HOMEWORK AND
IT'S EITHER THEY GO HERE THEY
GO JOIN A GANG IN THIS BILL
SUPPOSED TO BE DESIGNED. TO
HELP WITH THAT AS WELL. JUST
ENERGY IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ON
DEFINITIONS PLEASE CONTACT MY
OFFICE I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT-THIS IS NOT A BILL. FOR A MONEY
GRAB FOR MEGA CHURCHES IN
PASTORS FLYING ON PRIVATE JETS
THAT IS NOT THE INTENT OF THIS.
AND I WILL NOT ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN IN THIS BILL. SO IF YOU
HAVE THOSE CONCERNS PLEASE
CONTACT MY OFFICE I WILL BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO SIT DOWN AND
WORK WITH YOU THROUGH THOSE.
PLEASE HELP ME. HELP OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SENATORS ASK FOR MICHAEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I CONSULT WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS DID THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
AIKMAN HI. EIGHT MEN HI DOLLY.
HI DOLLY NINE. BETTER BAKER I
PORCHES ALL RIGHT PORGES I
BRADFORD OUR BRADFORD I DOT ALL
RIGHT DOT I GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ HI. GROSS. GROSS I.
HERTZBERG WESSEL. MIDWAY FIRE.
MAN HI MAN I WE'LL BE OKAY HI
RUBIO HI STERN. SURE THERE'S
EIGHT TEN DAYS OKAY THAT BILL
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NOW YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL
BEFORE US TODAY AP FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PROCEED AND
AGAIN THIS ONE HAS NO
OPPOSITION NO LEAD OPPOSITIONAL
LEAD SUPPORT SO. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU SENATOR. AND SENATORS.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX SIMPLY
LOOKS AT THE RIGHT OF FIRST
REFUSAL THAT HAS BEEN SLOWING
DOWN GETTING OUR BROADBAND
PROJECTS DONE THIS GOES IN WITH
A MICROSCOPE WE ARE WORKING
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED. THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
PROJECTS THAT ARE STILL. SEVEN
TO TEN YEARS LATER GOING
THROUGH PROCESS SEES IS AN
ISSUE WE ALL WONDERED HOW COME
WE DON'T HAVE A BROADBAND WHAT
IS TAKING SO LONG THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. AND WITH THAT I
SIMPLY ASK YOU HELP ME CUT THE
RED TAPE IN THE GREEN TAPE AND
ALL THE TAPES IN THE WAY WITH
ALL OUR BUREAUCRACIES IN LET'S
GET. ACCESS FOR EVERYONE THAT
YOU FORGOT ABOUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY SUPPORT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NONE I WOULD ASK THE
MODERATOR JUST TO CHECK THAT
PHONE LINE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYBODY WANTING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THE
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THE NATURE OF.
WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA LOOK FOR SOME
OPPOSITION ROOM ONE TWELVE I
DON'T SEE ANY THERE AT
MODERATOR HOW ABOUT ON THE
PHONE LINE ANY ANYBODY'S GOING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION FOR.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF BABY FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYBODY IN THE- BODY WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
AT CENTER DALLAS BUT THE
MANAGER OF THIS BILL ACTUALLY
DOES SOMETHING THIS IS THIS
BILL WILL GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- HOPEFULLY SPEED
UP THE PROCESS I AGREE WITH THE
AUTHORS- INTENT HERE- WE PUT IT
IN A B. TWENTY SIX SIXTY FIVE
THAT THERE WAS A FIRST REVIEWS
THEY HAVE THE FIRST RIGHT IF
THEY DON'T USE THAT RIGHT. BUT
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO MOVE
FORWARD SO WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST MOVE THE BILL.
AND- HELP YOU OUT THERE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO A MEMBER- THE
BILL HAS BEEN PROPERLY MOVED
AND CONSULT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. EIGHT MEN. BY
ADMIN HI DOLLY. HI DOLLY NINE
BECKER. BECKER HI FORGES ALL
RIGHT FORTUS NINE BRADFORD ALL
RIGHT RADFORD I. HI GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ HI GROSS HI HELLOHI
HERTZBERG. HURTS BIRD HI WESSEL
MCGUIRE. MAN MAN I RUBIO HI
RUBIO I STERN. SURE THERE'S
ELEVEN DAYS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO A MEMBER THAT YOU BUILD
SECOND BILL GETS OUT I WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- AND CONSULTANT I WOULD
ASK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
UNDER CONTROL THAT ASK YOU TO
OPEN A ROLE ON E. B. TEN FIFTY
EIGHT GARCIA. A. B. TEN FIFTY
EIGHT PRICE LAMBERT GARCIA DID
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GORGEOUS HERTZBERG WOULD YOU
JUST OKAY- I. WESSEL MCGUIRE I
MIKE WEIR HI THE STERN HI STERN
HI THEY'RE GOOD WE DON'T.
TWELVE A STIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN THE CLOSER ROLE ON THAT
AS THE NEXT BILL A. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE CONSULTANT COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI WESSEL.
MAGUIRE I REQUIRE I STERN. HI
STERN HI. SURE THAT'S THIRTEEN
EIGHTIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WILL ALSO CLOSE THE ROLE-
NOW WE MOVED TO AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX CONTROL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX BY SELLER
MATTHYS MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL. MCGUIRE.
HI MIKE WEIR I. STERN THE
OPERATOR. SURE THAT'S TWELVE
DAYS THANK YOU VERY MUCH CLOSER
ROLE ON THAT AND THAT CONCLUDES
OUR HEARING FOR TODAY AGAIN IF
YOU DID NOT GET TO MAKE A
COMMENT ON SOMETHING- WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU YOU CAN CONTACT THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATE STAFF-
BUT WITH THAT WE WILL. CLOSE A
ROLE. DURING THE MEETING.